good morning believe nation today's
message is choose anything over to you
Neil Strauss choose anything it doesn't
even matter just choose anything so
here's an example if you so I wish I
could almost draw it but I'll tell you
what like let's see what can I use is
that well use the back of this couch
here yeah this is you thumb head sure
maybe I don't even know something be
worthwhile but we'll say this right this
is you right and you're like I don't
know what to do I'm not sure what to do
and you just you're just sit or sitting
here doing nothing right this little
white stain IV know what it is this
Lamar Burton's back sweat
levar if I were to say I don't could be
anyone's sweat right there so so that's
you has a little piece of sweat toiling
and trying to aside what to do but then
just choose frigging anything let's just
say oh I want to be an actor just who
cares maybe you don't I don't know just
choose the one thing so you choose one
thing and now you have a goal right just
choose a goal it doesn't matter now
maybe you're gonna start going to
auditions you're going to auditions and
then wait you got a job but it's a
voiceover work it's or maybe it's on
radio you get a little radio gig right
so now you're like oh radio is fun I'm
gonna be a radio host and that's your
next goal and then then you get a call
to do like a voiceover on a cartoon or
something here and you're like okay I'll
be a cartoon voice and guess what now
you're actually moving and maybe you
will end up being a you know the the
voice of whatever you know on the next
Pixar movie or something like that
Eugene Mirman okay use the voice and
Bob's Burgers yeah yeah exactly along
with uh yeah there's so many good John H
John Benjamin oh he was awesome home
movies right anyway but the point is
like just just choose one thing to move
toward and then the path and then just
go with the path and you'll end up
somewhere with you staying here trying
to side what to do you'll still be here
in a year two years three years four
years just choose something you're kind
of like and don't hate and then start
moving toward it and you'll find that
the course and path of life will bring
you exactly we were supposed to be did
that do that work is a Compaq of the
couch I think this is so important
because too many entrepreneurs spends so
much time planning and planning and
planning and planning they won't do
anything until they have the
plan and you need to understand that
there is no such thing as a perfect plan
you need to start doing you need to
start taking action I look at my
business today and it's nowhere close to
what I thought I was gonna do I never
planned on having a popular website I
never wanted to be a youtuber I didn't
even want to write a book at the start I
never planned on any of these things
happen it wasn't part of my dream plan I
thought it was gonna be a speaker and I
showed up and I did my first event and
three people showed up and I just loved
it so much on paper look like a terrible
idea you can't get more than three
people to show up to a free event how
are you ever gonna turn this into a
money-making business quit now save
yourself a lot of frustration and
headache and go do something else I
think it's so important that you start I
never thought I was gonna run and own a
salsa dance school I didn't do any
dancing growing up and I came out of a
relationship and I wanted to pick up
dancing and I walk into a salsa class
and I am too tall and I don't speak
Spanish and I've never heard the music
before and I'd pick huge steps and I'm
learning as an adult all these things
against me in the perfect plan and Here
I am fast forward how many years later I
now run maybe the largest salsa day in
school in North America the key is that
you start and that you adjust you can
have a plan it's not just have zero plan
you can have a plan that you think makes
sense and that works and then go do
something about it stop just thinking
about it
stop just sitting at home planning more
plans plans on top of plans on top of
plans go do something about it because
some of your assumptions are going to be
wrong because once you get out into the
market you're gonna discover new things
that you couldn't have planned for
prepared for because opportunities are
gonna come to you and maybe that's the
right one to jump on to help drive them
forward start and adjust so the question
of the day today is I'm curious what was
something that you didn't see coming
what's an opportunity you jumped on that
wasn't part of your plan and that you're
doing right now I'm super curious to
find out
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Frank Orlando from Orlando
wealth com Frank thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really really
means a lot to me thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much loved and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso hey believe
nation we're working on a special top 10
of Neil Strauss as well and here's a
quick preview of some of the clips that
we're going to include I hope you enjoy
number-one rule of writing is this
nobody cares nobody cares about you they
don't care about your thoughts they
don't care about your ideas they don't
care about what you have to say what you
did yesterday or anything they do not
give a [ __ ]
and from there can you make them care
everything I write I assume that nobody
cares that they have no interest if I
start from that perspective and if I can
draw you in through the writing that's
where the story begins so just assume
start by sudden nobody cares and how can
you draw them into your story or your
point number two then one way to draw
them in is something called open loops
there's who here knows what an open loop
is closed then dead ones see the new
Doctor Strange movie then one scene that
cool calc you saw so is it good ok by
the way that's an open loop an open loop
was ask you what an open loop was and
then rather than explaining it I went on
to another subject and talked about dr.
strange or something so an open loop is
if I can start with something that
captures your attention and 98% he
didn't know what an open loop is you're
probably curious about it by now acts
have been talking for two minutes and
still have explained it yet right an
open loop is his is at the top can I
tell you something that that you're
interested in you want to know the
answer to and waits at the end how many
times that we just stayed through a
really shitty movie
justly wonder know what happens at the
end right you know it can be the worst
movie ever but I want to know how that
happened
right so an open so one is to use the
idea of open loops and and it's true in
relationships you meet someone you have
a lot of common with you start telling
all these stories you want it to
continue so an open loop is a great
to create injury because we're we're
creatures who love storytelling right
early early in its storytelling as part
of our sort of our DNA so so creating
open loops at the top of a post or in a
book is is really powerful for things
when someone gives you feedback or
criticism however its intended whether
ill are positive and so one is not to
take it in but to kind of catch it I
think of it like a catcher's mitt if you
tell me something you come across this
way I'll grab it and then I'll look at
it and I'll think okay is it true if
it's true cool I'll put it in and learn
from it I think it's not true cool I'll
throw it away no harm no foul I'm not
gonna dwell on it right and I think
everybody needs this in this world
because we're all on most of us are in
social media and we're all getting like
you know all our thoughts are getting
picked apart you know all the time so we
really need this more than ever then the
third one is you get it and it's a maybe
well I'm not sure you said this about me
I'm not sure you know what do you guys
think you know what do you think I lost
my friends and ask other people and get
some feedback and if it's true well cool
maybe I learn from if everyone's like
this is total nonsense ignore that dude
I throw it out but then there's a fourth
one and this is where the real growth is
you know what the fourth one is I don't
the fourth one is you get it you throw
it out I'm talking to you and I maybe
later I'm talking to you know you I get
it
and I'm like no that's not sure I throw
it out and then later I'm talking to
someone else I get it it's a third time
it's come back to me I throw it out I'm
like wait maybe I got to take this thing
a little more seriously and it becomes
it maybe and then it becomes a yes and
that's when the big row thing is because
you kept ignoring this thing that was in
your face so the best feedback like when
you really grow is you keep getting the
same feedback you keep dismissing it at
some point you say wait maybe they have
something so one way I do this is I get
together a group of people and we sit
together once a week
and talk about stuff going on our lives
I find group therapy pop really powerful
because if it's just one-on-one I think
just say I disagree with you but when
four or five people are saying hey dude
no you're really coming off like that or
you're really having this problem your
relationship and maybe need to look at
it and five people are saying it like it
it's pretty hard to dismiss them we
treat ourselves for
we talk to ourselves and ways that we
would never ever a lot of stranger to
talk to us right we if something if I if
I if somebody here month up to you and
say you're not evening you've got
nothing good to say so why do we have
hours not to talk to herself that way
right so there's sort of a message I can
give you guys today
approaching Titan is there treating
yourself the way you want that person
you're approaching tree Christ if she
said that she's had to say anything
happens mean you're telling yourself
because you've already get yourself the
worst of it I I think like one thing
this whole weekend would be to stop
talking yourself this for me so every
motion has its corresponding action you
may be able to fear of rejection right
but where is that coming from if you
were sent like you were saying earlier
if you're giving a centerline norworth
and down your higher status than
yourself
and then what's that thing that Shan
Shan what who you are and you're not
worthy to talk to this books shame that
this person someone's gonna have some
power over you are going to hurt you
that you're not enough that you're not
good enough that you're not attractive
than that that you're not rich enough
you're not socially comfortable enough
that you're too offered whatever it is
that shame about who you are
and what happened is right your shame
when you walked in it in turns to Jordan
so the overall idea is if you there a
Promotora place of curing your purpose
of joining the several places shaming
you will have no broken inside that's
what we call what I call what they call
that in the end is being in the States
you know being in state it's just what
really just having joys they were all
things if you walk out there like okay
all right there all these people and
they're gonna approve of me and they
approve of me I'm gonna feel good about
myself but they don't approve them
they're gonna kill myself and and I'm
gonna go out and put my self-esteem in
the hands of every stranger I talk to
you're just setting yourself up for
trouble yeah push past it gives a lot of
stuff all that talk about that you're
starting off with a judge I've
handicapped